is the former mayor of South Bend
Indiana and a 2020 Democratic
presidential candidate peak Buddha
judges here hey there mayor Pete how you
doing I know you have to run cuz you got
to get urine anyway you got a campaign
stop very soon right that's right we're
in Davenport right now the snow is
flying but feels good here on the ground
ok so I'll get right to the questions
first of all I was ending there with
some commentary about Bernie and Biden
who seemed to be now neck-and-neck at
the head of the pack as the youngest guy
in the campaign what do you think about
that that that this party that so
young-looking
is embracing the two oldest people well
I suppose you could run and succeed at
any age but I think the really important
thing is are we focusing on the future
or are we tied up in the politics in the
past and I think at a moment like this
in order to govern but also in order to
win we got to be focused on the future
definitely in order to govern because
we're dealing with cybersecurity threats
of global health risks the economy
changing in the era of technology but
also in order to win the election most
of the folks I talked to mainly just
want to be sure we beat Donald Trump and
if you think about it for a minute every
single time that my party has captured
the White House in the last 50 years
it's been with a candidate who is
looking to the future new to national
politics and opening the door to a new
generation
I think I was a very clever answer mayor
Pete mentioning all those things old
people don't understand and I gotta say
that's why I like you you're good I must
tell you you were on the show a buddy
writer no less than a year ago but at
the time very few of us had heard of you
or could pronounce your name and of
course we still can't so we call you
mayor Pete multiple-choice pronounce it
you just got to be able to pick me off a
list or stand in the right corner for
the caucus well but for me just as a
voter age is not an issue anymore when I
just heard about you I didn't hear you
it kind of was but I think you're a lot
more mature than some of these people so
a I mean Ages is a case-by-case basis
and also I think what I like about you
is I don't think you'll have to change
your answers like some of the candidates
for the general election that's right I
mean look part of how we're gonna win is
to pull in a broad coalition and there
are a lot of what I like to call future
former Republicans who are showing up in
my event we didn't campaigning in some
counties in Iowa here they've swung
maybe 20 points toward Donald Trump and
yet folks are coming out of the woodwork
to my events and I'm not trying to trick
them I'm not pretending to be a
conservative but I'm making sure that we
have a vision that a good healthy
majority of Americans can get on board
with and that's not just true in terms
of policy is your trips a tone and style
and just the kind of president that I
think we want right now you know
president you could turn on the news and
see and feel your blood pressure
actually go down instead of up through
the roof that's what the desires of
father's party wine
I'll have to change up to the general
right I mean a month or two ago it
looked like for the for the far left and
and let's be clear you're a progressive
there's not a Democrat in this race who
wasn't an honest progressive some are
just very far left and that would be
Bernie and Elizabeth Warren and he seems
to have eclipsed her now and I think
that's because Bernie don't care about
that woek stuff you know Bernie's just
straight up about the economy and I
think that's what people care about
would you assess it similarly well I
think that racial and economic
inequality and justice go together what
we've got to do is make sure that we're
pointing to all the patterns of
exclusion that need to change and when I
talk about building a culture of
belonging for the country it's making
sure that people can thrive regardless
of where they come from regardless of
their race and and that you can thrive
wherever you sit in the economy I mean
again right now we're in Eastern Iowa in
cities that are a lot like South Bend
and yeah you know you've got a president
who said he cares about the Forgotten
men and women and industrial workers but
you look at all of the economic policies
they've had and they're benefiting
corporations are benefiting the wealthy
they're not doing anything for workers
for farmers people can tell and that is
increasingly something that's not just
important to progressive and
dyed-in-the-wool Democrats but really
mattering to independence and an awful
lot of people getting ready to cross
party lines okay well when I said woke I
meant a broad range of issues but I'm as
long as you mentioned this I just want
to say and again you don't have to
comment in this but just again as a
voter to the media I would say one story
I'm really tired of as Pete is not
connecting with black voters yes I heard
that story many many times get it and
can we move on and you know III worry it
becomes a self-fulfilling prophecy do
you well that's why it's so important to
do well here on the ground you know the
strongest support that I have among
black voters is among the folks who know
me best in South Bend where most of the
black elected officials who've made
endorsements are supporting me and on
the ground in Iowa we're seeing a
to support but look the reality April
and I ORS have every reason I mean look
not in the non of the numbers you see in
the South but no absolutely their
experience matters and and it counts and
look this is really important right I
mean nobody is experiencing more of the
pain of living under the Trump
presidency than communities of color and
that is one of the reasons there's such
an emphasis on making sure that we win
and the process of proving that for all
of us begins right here in Iowa and this
is the chance starting in three days
with the caucuses to demonstrate that
I've got the kind of campaign
organization to succeed and go on and
beat Donald Trump okay so I very often
here I used the phrase patriotic
immunity meaning Republicans seem to be
able to get away with doing things that
are unpatriotic and it doesn't stick to
them like Trump sides with countries not
named America versus Obama wore a tan
suit you know stuff like that that just
seems like we're playing two different
games you know you're the only military
veteran in this but it seems like
America cares less about that than they
used to you'd be the first one with
military service to be elected since the
first president Bush sorry I should and
I think
I mean here you got a present right
who will thump his chest throw himself a
military parade and then turns his back
on the troops I mean the latest was
minimizing traumatic brain injury if you
know anything about what has happened to
troops in the post 9/11 war so you know
that one thing I can tell you about
traumatic brain injury is it can be a
lot more serious than bone spurs that's
why I honestly think you would do very
well in a debate with Donald Trump I do
but all right I know you gotta go I'm
gonna ask you one last question and I
know I nagged people about this and
maybe they're tired of it but I laid it
out last week in a way I've never laid
it out before but all down the line I
don't think if Trump loses he's going to
concede scenario you win your president
elect Pete we're still calling you Pete
and you win but Trump says the
irregularities and he can't give up the
office because it's a deep state hoax
what do you do well it's gonna be a
little awkward when Chaston and I are
moving into the White House but that was
really the last question then I wouldn't
be doing my job if I didn't ask
everybody watching who supports this
campaign to go to Pete for america.com
and send in five or ten bucks
actually this HBO so you feel free to do
100 I'm a big fan mayor Pete everybody's
you